[Musik]
man kommt ja kaum noch hinterher Boris
Johnson haben wir vor ein paar Wochen
mit einem Video verabschiedet jetzt
seine Nachfolgerin List Trust und da wir
hier auf visualpolitik nicht den
Rücktritt vermelden wollen sondern auch
hinter die Kulissen schauen macht das
Ganze Personalkarussell schon ein wenig
Arbeit bei dieser Frequenz könnte es
sich vielleicht lohnen schon mal einen
Video Nachruf auf Regie sunak zu drehen
aber kommen wir erst einmal zu List
Trust sie ist am 20 Oktober
zurückgetreten und sunack ist ihr
Nachfolger der vier Tage später sein Amt
antrat aber warum eigentlich dieser
irrsinnig schneller Rücktritt von Trust
nach nur sechs Wochen wie ihr als
interessierte Beobachters Weltgeschehens
garantiert Arndt hatte der Rücktritt mit
Amtsmüdigkeit absolut nichts zu tun
Trust stand nach nur wenigen Wochen im
Amt massiv unter Druck aber war die
heftige Kritik welcher sie letztlich
nicht mehr standhalten konnte überhaupt
fair und gerechtfertigt oder direkt noch
mehr dahinter was können wir aus Ihrem
Fall lernen lasst uns doch heute wie
gesagt einen Blick hinter die Kulissen
werfen und den Hauptgrund beleuchten aus
dem Trust so schnell verschwinden musste
wie sie aufgetaucht war das ganze war
nämlich alles andere als ein Zufall
[Musik]
alles begann im September mit einem
heftigen Stresstest für das britische
Pfund komischerweise fast genau 30 Jahre
nach dem schwarzen Mittwoch von 1992
damals spekulierte der Investor George
storage gegen das britische Pfund
erhielt es für überbewertete mit
milliardenstrument dagegen und zwar mit
Erfolg die Bank of England musste die
Währung abwerten sprich die Zinsen
senken das Pfund verlor 15% gegenüber
D-Mark und 25% zu US-Dollar George
sorosh machte einen Milliarden Reibach
vor 30 Jahren waren es Investoren
historisch die der Bank of England und
dem food zusetzen am 23 September 2023
war es aber die englische Regierung
selbst die heftigste Turbulenzen
auslöste die Furcht vor einer neuen
globalen Finanzkrise zog plötzlich auf
doch diesmal nicht von Manhattan
ausgehen sondern von Downing Street
number ten
Großbritannien könnte eine globale Krise
auslösen wenn das Pfund kollabiert und
die anleiherrenditen in die Höhe
schnellen sagt Larry Summers
typischerweise sind Staatsanleihen und
deren Zinssätze Gradmesser für die
wirtschaftliche Stabilität eines Landes
die niedriger die Zinsen umso stabiler
die Volkswirtschaft und umgekehrt die
Zinsen sind also ein Risikoaufschlag
doch schaut mal wie sich diese Zinsen
auf britische Anleihen in den
vergangenen zwölf Monaten entwickelt
haben in weniger als einem Jahr hat sich
der vom Markt geforderte Zinssatz also
der Risikoaufschlag für britische
Staatsanleihen verzehnfacht
[Musik]
die britische Zentralbank konnte noch
Ende 2021 Anleihen für gerade mal 0,4%
Zinsen ausgeben aber mit der pfund-krise
schnellten die Zinssätze hoch auf über
4%. und zu allem Überfluss gab es auch
noch Nachrichten wie diese Inflation im
Vereinigten Königreich könnte nächstes
Jahr 22% erreichen warnt Goldman Sachs
was um Himmels willen war da in London
los wie kam es dazu dass die Kosten der
britischen Schulden die von Ländern wie
Spanien Griechenland und Italien
überstiegen und die wichtigste Frage von
allen ist List Trust deswegen
zurückgetreten nun ihr ahnt sicher das
Problem liegt tiefer wir schauen uns
dafür die britische Wirtschaft genauer
an aber das ganze hat auch politische
Dimensionen ihr Rücktritt ist eng
verbunden mit der Situation in der
konservativen Story Partei die Trust bis
vor kurzem anführte und unsere
Einschätzung Nachkommen auf ihren
nachfolgerische gewaltige Probleme zu
um es klar zu sagen das Vereinigte
Königreich hat nicht erst seit List
Trust ein erstes Problem seit der
Finanzkrise von 2008 ist die Wirtschaft
nicht mehr dieselbe hier ein Beispiel
wie ihr sehen könnt war Großbritannien
ist einzige G7 Mitglied dessen
Wirtschaft Mitte 2022 kleiner war als
vor der Pandemie selbst die Erholung
eines problemlandes der Italien verlief
besser
aber das ist nur die Spitze des Eisbergs
seit der Finanzkrise ist das reale pro
Kopf BIP im Vereinigten Königreich kaum
noch gewachsen es ist weit hinter Länder
die den USA und Deutschland
zurückgefallen wir sprechen hier von
einem Unterschied von fast 10% Punkten
[Musik]
das heißt weniger als 4% in 14 Jahren
das hat dazu geführt das Großbritannien
Schulden machen musste um staatliche
Dienstleistungen im Land weiterhin zu
gewährleisten man griff dazu aber auch
den Bürgern in die Tasche um den Staat
am Laufen zu halten und die Schulden zu
bezahlen die Briten leiden heute unter
der höchsten Steuerbelastung seit 40
Jahren und die Insel hat noch ein
anderes großes Problem Mangel wird
Produktivität
[Musik]
zwischen 208 und 2020 ist die
Arbeitsproduktivität in Großbritannien
nur 0,4% gestiegen das ist weniger als
die Hälfte des oecd-durchschnitts in
barer Münze ausgedrückt bedeutet das die
Briten haben im Vergleich zu Ländern wie
Frankreich und Deutschland 4.000 Euro
pro Kopf verloren tja Wachstum schlecht
Produktivität schlecht warum zum Teufel
geht da nichts so recht voran auf der
Insel nun will man es sich genau ansieht
hat man den Eindruck das Land wolle gar
kein Industrieland mehr sein denn die
Unternehmensinvestitionen also der
Investitionen in Maschinenfabriken
Computer Arbeitsplätze sind auf einem
nie da gewesenen Tiefstand bei diesen
Investitionen hat es den niedrigsten
Wert aller G7 Länder sogar Italien hat
besser abgeschnitten
gut es gibt eine Branche in der das Land
Spitze ist oder besser gesagt in der die
Londoner City Spitze ist
natürlich ist von der Finanzbranche die
rede ich verlinke euch hierzu ein Video
das wir mal über die Macht der City
gemacht haben mit dieser
hyperspezialisierung im Finanzbereich
hat man aber andere Branchen völlig per
nachlässigt und das hat Folgen für
England wo London und seine Banken
blühen den Rest des Landes aber brach
liegt weil da kaum noch investiert wird
dieses krasse Missverhältnis hat das
Vereinigte Königreich zudem von der
Außenwelt völlig abhängig gemacht viele
Dinge dann einfach nicht mehr im Lande
hergestellt und müssen importiert werden
das hat so einem Leistungsbilanzdefizit
von über 8% geführt die Briten müssen
also so viel mehr einführen als im
Handel mit anderen Ländern verkaufen
können die Importe übersteigen die
Exporte also bei weitem
gut in den USA ist das mit dem
Leistungsbilanzdefizit auch ähnlich die
kaufen auch mehr als sie verkaufen aber
dort ist das Problem ein ganz anderes
der Knackpunkt ist nämlich Vertrauen das
Vertrauen der Investoren muss so groß
sein dass sie die Anleihen des
jeweiligen Landes kaufen zum Beispiel
amerikanische Anleihen in US-Dollar der
derzeit der Dicke da steht ganz anders
beim Pfund hier fiel das Vertrauen in
die Kraft und Stabilität des Königreichs
innerhalb weniger Tage und Zweifel an
Großbritannien ist ökonomischer Potenz
kommen einem auch bei einem Blick auf
die Löhne im Land
[Musik]
die britischen Gehälter sind niedriger
als die in Frankreich oder Deutschland
vor 15 Jahren waren sie aber noch höher
sie sind zwischen 2010 und 2019
praktisch überhaupt nicht mehr gewachsen
zudem sind die britischen Haushalt in
der niedrigen Einkommen im Vergleich
auch viel ärmaus warum 20%
ärmer als französische und deutsche
Haushalte
zu allem Überfluss hat die
Staatsverschuldung in Prozent des BIP
den höchsten staatsan 1960 erreicht also
der kranke Mann Europas lebt auf der
Insel mit dieser Diagnose war listras
bei ihrem Amtsantritt konfrontiert eine
Therapie musste her und die hieß Crosser
norwegs solche Worte entstehen wenn eine
Wirtschaftspolitik wirklich stark von
einem führenden Politiker geprägt wird
Ronald Reagan und regonomics sind ein
anderes Beispiel dafür ist Trust ging
also voll motiviert ansberg schaut her
im nächsten top-times we need to step up
der Plan
[Musik]
nur zwei Wochen nach ihrem Amtsantritt
in Downing Street number Tag legt die
neue Regierung von listrasse los und
präsentiert ein Wirtschaftsprogramm das
alles veränderte es brach völlig mit der
Politik der konservativen Partei des
letzten Jahrzehnts und dieses
Wirtschaftsprogramm das schließlich der
große standesanstoß wurde sehen wir uns
jetzt mal genauer an listras kündigte
gemeinsam mit ihrem damaligen
Finanzminister quasi quarting eine Reihe
von Steuersenkungen und die Abschaffung
von Vorschriften an und beides hatte es
in sich zugleich war aber auch noch die
Erhöhung der öffentlichen Ausgaben
geplant in der Hoffnung damit die
britische Wirtschaft wieder anzukurbeln
das wesentliche Ziel des Plans war es
die Umverteilungspolitik abzuschaffen
und sich ganz auf Produktion und
Produktivität zu konzentrieren einfach
ausgedrückt man wollte aufhören ständig
darüber nachzudenken wie man das Geld
verteilt und sich darauf konzentrieren
wie man es wieder verdient man wollte
Schluss machen mit einer Politik der
hohen Steuerlasten und hört zu was der
Finanzminister dazu sagte völlig
unhaltbar war die Vorstellung wir
könnten uns einfach mit Steuern zum
Wohlstand durchschlagen und damit
Steuersätze auf einem des Jahreshoch
durchbrechen wo sollte das enden quasi
quatten Schatzkanzler kleiner Einschub
Trust und Quartet sind alte Bekannte der
Plan mit den Steuersenkungen ist nicht
mit heißer Nadel gestrickt in wenigen
Stunden entworfen worden ganz und gar
nicht im Jahr 2012 haben die beiden
gemeinsam das Buch Bretagne ja unchaine
verfasst in dem bereits genau
nachzulesen war was sie nun tun wollten
ja und jetzt bekamen sie die Gelegenheit
dazu doch was genau sah das Programm vor
nur zum einen sollte es die größte
Steuersenkung Seite 1972 geben
konkret Unternehmensgewinne sollten nur
noch mit 19% besteuert werden die
Einkommensteuer sollte um einen
Prozentpunkt senken auf 44% auch Kapital
und Vermögen sollte weniger besteuert
werden Sozialversicherungsbeträge
sollten sinken Verbrauch Steuern sollten
eine Zeit lang eingefroren werden unter
Spitzensteuersatz sollte um 5% Punkte
fallen für sich allein genommen war jede
einzelne Steuersenkung nicht zu
gravierend alles zusammen jedoch ergibt
die größte Steuersenkung die eine
britische Regierung in den letzten fünf
Jahrzehnten durchge wie ihr aber wisst
wurden viele dieser Steuersenkungen
wieder zurückgenommen nicht von sonak
sondern noch unter Trust und wie es im
Einzelnen weitergeht darüber debattiert
das ganze Land noch immer
das Thema Steuern steht bei den ganzen
Wirbel und Trust und ihre kurze Amtszeit
sehr im Vordergrund einige andere Dinge
sind jedoch beschlossen worden und
werden wohl bleiben einige Regulierungen
zum Beispiel
[Musik]
so werden die gesetzlichen Grenzen für
Boni im Finanzsektor derzeit ausgesetzt
eine Grenze die 2014 von der
Europäischen Union festgelegt wurde das
freut natürlich die Banker wie ihr hier
seht wir begrüßen die klare Richtung und
den neuen Ansatz der schatzkanzlers und
sein klares Bekenntnis zum Finanzsektor
als Katalysator für die britische
Wirtschaft die heute angekündigten
Maßnahmen sind der Anfang dessen was
nötig ist um die volle Stärke des
Sektors zu entfalten Erklärung von UK
final System britischen Handelsverband
der Finanzbranche außerdem wurde die
Einrichtung zahlreicher sondern
Wirtschaftszonen in ganzen Land
angekündigt diese Zonen werden bestimmte
Steuervorteile und regelerleichterungen
genießen ihr wichtigstes Ziel soll sein
Investitionen von Unternehmen anzulocken
investitionszonen bieten nicht nur mehr
steuerliche Anreise im Unternehmen
anzuziehen sondern reduzieren auch die
Bürokratie und den langwierigen
Planungsprozess der Investitionen oft
ganz verhindert aber legen wir mal
Steuerpolitik und Investitionspläne
beiseite was ist derzeit das
besorgniserregendste Problem in Europa
2 1 ganz genau die Energie oder vielmehr
die Energiekosten
[Musik]
aufgrund von Putins illegale Invasion in
der Ukraine und im Einsatz von Energie
als Waffe hat die Stärkung unserer
Energiesicherheit absolute Priorität
Jacob Resort Wirtschaftsminister unter
Trass die Regierung Trust hatte in
dieser Angelegenheit sehr deutlich
gemacht dass da einige Königreich muss
ich ergiebige und gleichzeitig billige
Energiequellen schaffen dafür blieben
die Pläne der Vorgängerregierung zu
Kernenergie erhalten neue
Rohstoffquellen wollte man in der
Nordsee erschließen und Fracking sollte
wieder erlaubt sein oder besser gesagt
kündigte man das Ende des monatoriums
dafür an tja niedrige Steuern
Deregulierung sondern Wirtschaftszonen
und Fracking das klingt wieder goldene
Traum vom brexit zumindest jedes brexit
in die Konservativen und die Befürworter
des freien Marktes haben wollten nicht
wahr
[Musik]
wir sprechen über ein riesiges Paket von
Maßnahmen dass man in der Ökonomie als
angebotsseitige Maßnahmen bezeichnet das
Ziel war die britische Wirtschaft
wiedergesunden zu lassen und zum
Wachstum zurückzukehren und eigentlich
klingt es alles doch gar nicht so
schlecht ob man den brexit nun mag oder
nicht Wachstum ist immer gut für eine
[Musik]
Wirtschafts a less money to spend on the
things the make love better und da hatte
List Trust auf jeden Fall recht wie er
bereits wisst der Plan der Regierung
endete mit einer
notfall-intervention der Zentralbank um
den Absturz des Pfunds zu stoppen und
Trust musste viele ihrer Pläne
zurücknehmen warum um alles in der Welt
sind die Märkte aber wegen einer
Steuersenkung so nervös geworden
normalerweise begrüßen Anleger doch eine
weniger startpolitik durch weil sie die
Regierung den Leuten weniger Geld
abknöpft
[Musik]
nun ja meine Lieben Zuschauer die
Antwort hat viel mit dem zweiten Teil
des just-plans zu tun denn neben
Steuersenkungen wäre Regulierungen und
Fracking hat die Regierung auch eine
massive Erhöhung der öffentlichen
Ausgaben versprochen also eher doch
nicht weniger Staat die Regierung hat
zum Beispiel einen energiepreisdeckel
für Haushalte und Unternehmen
angekündigt die Differenz zu den
tatsächlichen Energiekosten soll durch
eine Subvention abgedeckt werden die der
Staat zahlt nun werdet ihr einblenden
dass auch andere Staaten wie zum
Beispiel Deutschland eine solche
energiepreisbremse eingeführt haben aber
wie ihr der folgenden Grafik entnehmen
könnt handelt es sich beim britischen
Vorhaben um nichts Geringeres als das
größte Energie Subventionsprogramm in
Europa im Verhältnis zum BIP kleine
Korrektur der Grafik laut den jüngsten
Ankündigungen der deutschen Regierung
betragen die Energie Subvention nun
knapp über 5% des BIP aber davon
unabhängig besprechen in Großbritannien
von gigantischen Kosten die zwischen 100
und 200 Milliarden Pfund liegen dürfte
die Subvention sollten Haushalte und
Wirtschaft vor zu hohen Energiepreisen
bewahren bis man alternative
Energiequellen für eine günstigere
Versorgung gefunden hat aber das könnte
eine Weile dauern sowohl in
Großbritannien als auch im übrigen
Europa die Folge die Staatsausgaben
werden noch lange Zeit hoch bleiben
ebenso wie die Schulden
Kosten lauern auch in einem anderen
Bereich bis zum Ende dieses Jahrzehnts
wird das Vereinigte Königreich seinen
Militärhaushalt auf 100 Milliarden Pfund
erhöhen das bedeutet mehr als eine
Verdoppelung des derzeitigen militärtags
und eine Erhöhung der Militärausgaben
auf 3% des BIP in nur 8 Jahren von nun
an wird der britische Militärhaushalt
jedes Jahr also großzügig wachsen das
bedeutet mehr Ausgaben mehr Defizit und
mehr Schulden und da haben wir es diese
Kombination aus Steuersenkungen und
ausgabenerhöhungen sind eine riesige
fiskalische Bombe kein Wunder dass
Investoren hier das Vertrauen in
Großbritannien verloren haben denn so
wie ursprünglich von Trust veranschlagt
hätten ihre Maßnahmen zu einer
Schuldensumme von schätzungsweise 80
Milliarden Brot zusätzlich pro Jahr
geführt die Schulden des Landes während
ein fast ohne Boden geworden und
angesichts dessen fragt man sich gibt es
denn keine Kontrollinstanz in
Großbritannien doch eigentlich schon und
zwar das Office for budget
responsibility eine Kontrollbehörde
geschaffen unter David Cameron
allerdings hat Trust ihren Plan diesen
Amt nie vorgelegt die kon hätten ihn ja
auch gehörig auseinander genommen
stattdessen Plasten die Pläne in die
Welt hinaus und dann passierte das
folgende
Panik
die Präsentation des Plans hatte drei
unmittelbare Auswirkungen erstens
stürzte das Pfund ab und erreichte seine
tiefsten Stand gegenüber dem Dollar
zweitens stiegen die Renditen von
Staatsanleihen sogar über jene von
Ländern wie Italien Griechenland und
Spanien die sind ja sonst eher die
Sorgenkinder in Europa seht euch das
Desaster am besten mal selbst an
höchster Anspannung in Großbritannien
das Pfund stürzt auf den Tiefstand von
1971 und die anleiherrenditen liegen bei
4,2 Prozent und drittens drohte
angesichts der beiden ersten Folgen ein
riesiger Finanzcrash bei den Rentenfonds
warum nun Renten oder Pensionsfonds sind
Anbieter für private Altersvorsorge von
Millionen von Menschen in Großbritannien
auch in den USA ist dieses System üblich
die Menschen zahlen Jahre lang in diese
Fonds ein im Alter so daraus eine
garantierte Rente werden denn das Geld
der Anleger investieren die
Pensionskassen in der Zeit bis zur
Rentenauszahlung deswegen sind diese
Fonds gewissen Beschränkungen
unterworfen und dürfen nicht einfach
wild herum zocken schließlich werden
hier Rentenzahlungen garantiert die
Pensionsfonds müssen also so gut
investieren dass ich für sie selbst das
Geschäft lohnt und sie immer noch retten
auszahlen können bei ihren Investments
setzen solche Pensionsfonds daher oft
auf Staatsanleihen die gelten ja als
sicher meistens zumindest
wegen ihrer hohen Stabilität nutzen die
Pensionskassen die Staatsanleihen aber
gerne auch als Sicherheiten anderer
riskanter Geldgeschäfte zum Beispiel mit
Zins Derivaten bei Derivaten ist es
üblich dass Investoren Sicherheiten wie
etwa Anleihen hinterlegen und es ist
auch üblich dass die Sicherheiten erhöht
werden müssen wenn es Turbulenzen am
Finanzmarkt gibt
[Musik]
genau das ist passiert es rumpelte
ordentlich im Karton als die
trustregierung teure Maßnahmen
ankündigte die aber das Schuldenkonto
der dritten massiv vergrößerten
Investoren verloren Vertrauen in die
wirtschaftliche Stabilität
Großbritannien und verkauften die
Staatsanleihen des Landes diese verloren
folglich an Wert zugleich verloren wir
hinterlegten Sicherheiten an Wert und
die passionskassen mussten Sicherheiten
nachschießen aber die Sicherheiten die
sie üblicherweise bieten können waren
wiederum Anleihen die jetzt an Wert
verloren hatten was sollten sie also tun
die Anleihen im großen Stil verkaufen
und Cash hinterlegen das hätte die
Anleihe Kurse noch weiter gedrückt es
drohte also an gigantisches
Verlustgeschäft für die passionskassen
dass eine Abwärtsspirale ausgelöst hätte
denn damit drohte auch ein massiver
Wertverlust anderer Wertpapiere wie etwa
Aktien einfach weil die Passionsfrucht
Cash brauchten für die Sicherheiten sie
hätten dafür nämlich im großen Stil auch
andere Wertpapiere wie etwa Aktien
verkaufen müssen das alles sind typische
Ansteckungseffekte die eine Finanzkrise
auslösen und zwar weil große Player im
Markt große Anteile verschiedene
Anlageklassen zu verkaufen müssen um an
Cash zu kommen und an dieser Stelle
musste die Bank of England einschreiten
sie hat mit einem 65 Milliarden Pfund
schweren Notfallplan eingegriffen eine
globale Finanzkrise sollte verhindert
werden mit dieser Intervention und dem
Versprechen der Regierung einen
haushaltstabilitätsplan vorzulegen
wurden die Nerven der Anleger beruhigt
und damit hatte sich dann auch das Pfund
in der teilweise erholt allerdings nur
teilweise ein Misstrauen sind die Märkte
bis heute aber warum eigentlich nun
Großbritannien hat Schulden und mit
welchen Maßnahmen auch immer eine
gültige Regierung die Wirtschaft wieder
auf Vordermann bringen will sie muss
dafür neue Schulden aufnehmen und diese
sind mittlerweile ziemlich teuer
geworden wir reden ja nicht mehr von
Zinssätzen nah 0 wie es nur vor einiger
Zeit der Fall war auch bei den
zehnjährigen Staatsanleihen zahlt das
dann derzeit über 3% Zinsen zum
Vergleich Anfang 2022 lag dieser Wert
noch bei einem Prozent das Vertrauen in
die wirtschaftliche Stabilität hat im
Vergleich zu früher Schaden genommen das
Pfund sonst als stabile Währung
gehandelt ist in Gefahr es besteht ein
echtes Risiko das internationale
Investoren das Vertrauen in die BR
Regierung verlieren was zu einer
pfund-krise führen wird der Markt fragt
wie wollt ihr das bezahlen und wenn das
Foto weiter an Wert verlieren sollte
hätte das noch einen weiteren Effekt es
würde Kosten für Importe und das
Leistungsbilanz der erhöhen wenn dieses
Szenario Eintritt und eine englische
Regierung gleichzeitig viele Schulden
macht könnte die Zentralbank gezwungen
sein die Zinssätze weiter anzuheben um
die Inflation zu bekämpfen um das Pfund
zu stabilisieren aber dann könnten die
hohen Zinsen das Wachstum abwirken dass
sie die Nachfrage nach Krediten und
Investitionsprojekten verringern das
ganze Land würde in einer
rezessionslittern fassen wir also kurz
zusammen wirtschaftlich hat das Land
große Probleme und vor allem Schulden
die Regierung Trust stellte einen Plan
auf um Wachstum anzukurbeln der aber das
Schuldenproblem noch verschlimmerte das
kann bei internationalen Investoren so
schlecht an dass man fast eine globale
Finanzkrise auslöste
listras hat also in Sachen Wirtschafts-
und Fiskalpolitik ein gigantischen Bock
geschossen der das Land innerhalb von
ein paar Tagen Milliarden zurückgekostet
hat und immer noch gekostet weil die
Schulden oder besser der Schuldendienst
in Zinsen jetzt höher ausfällt da hat
auch die teilweise Rücknahme der
Maßnahme und die Entlastung von
Finanzminister quasi quarktängen nach
bereits 38 Tagen am nicht viel genutzt
es ist wie ein Imageschaden der nur sehr
langsam vergeht solch ein Patzer kostet
im übrigen auch belieb bei den WLAN und
Zustimmung in den eigenen Reihen der
Regierung und der Partei und damit wären
wir auch schon bei den politischen
Gründen für das Scheitern von der Straße
aufgepasst
[Musik]
ohne Mehrheiten geht es nicht
Fehler von Regierungschefs können
zumindest bis zu einer gewissen schwere
immer noch verziehen werden es muss ja
nicht gleich eine Rücktritt sein und
tatsächlich kam es eher Zurücknahme
vieler masdamen aber Fehler Kosten neben
Geld eben auch Gefolgschaft und die ist
in einer Demokratie wichtig um
Mehrheiten für eigene Vorhaben zu
bekommen und da sah es ebenso düster aus
vertras ihre konservative tori-partei
ist tief zerstritten und in mindestens
zwei Lager geteilt wir haben dazu schon
etwas im Youtube Boris Johnson erzählt
dass ich euch verlinke und es gibt nach
wie vor Streit zwischen Befürwortern des
brexit und seinen Gegnern und seit
Johnsons abtritt ist es eher noch
schlimmer geworden in der Abstimmung zum
Thema Fracking Ende Oktober einen Tag
vor Trust Rücktritt soll es sogar so
Handgreiflichkeiten innerhalb der Partei
gekommen sein Trust konnte sich für die
Abstimmungen im Parlament nicht sicher
sein ob ihre eigene Partei oder
zumindest Teile davon überhaupt
mitziehen aber ohne stabile Mehrheiten
kann keine Regierung in einer Demokratie
irgendwas bewegen es bleibt nur der
Rücktritt auch im Regierungsteam
bröckelte es erheblich es muss ja nicht
nur Finanzminister quasi greaten gehen
die
innenministerman hat ein paar Tage
später zurück sie galt nicht gerade als
Unterstützerin von Trust und kritisierte
auch offen deren Wirtschaftspolitik
übrigens brotherman ist inzwischen
wieder auf ihren Posten zurückgekehrt
denn sie gilt als eine Unterstützerin
von Regie sunak
[Musik]
und für zulag bleibt vor allem ein
schwieriges Erbe die Gespaltenheit der
Tories ist ja ist nicht einfach weg auch
er braucht Mehrheiten Gefolgschaft und
Leute die mitziehen und er wird um
erfolgreich zu sein die Tories irgendwie
einigen müssen die sind aber auch in den
aktuellen Umfragen äußerst geschwächt
sie würden bei einer Wahl zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt rund 25% Hinterleger liegen
und ihre Abgeordneten Flügen reihenweise
aus dem Unterhaus hinaus es ist kein
Wunder dass sie frustriert sind aber
auch dass sie Neuwahlen fürchten
[Musik]
halten wir fest Trust hat schwere Fehler
in ihrer Wirtschaftspolitik gemacht die
allein schon einen Rücktritt für
angebracht erschienen ließen der
mangelnde Rückhalt in ihrer eigenen
Partei und deren Zerstrittenheit ließen
das fast an aber wirklich zu überlaufen
bringen angesichts dieser Probleme steht
zu nach vor extrem schwierigen Aufgaben
er muss die Wirtschaft auf Vordermann
bringen Schulden abbauen ist eigene Land
durch die Energiekrise führen und ach ja
Krieg ist ja auch noch in Europa die
derzeitige Außenpolitik Management auch
nicht so gerade nebenbei und dann sind
da noch die eigenen Partei Leute die
Tories die sich selbst die größten
Gegner sind vielleicht ist dieser Job
ein schweres Himmelfahrtskommando
vielleicht ist das der Grund weshalb
auch ein Boris Johnson nicht wieder als
Premier antrat obwohl ist diese Gerüchte
ja gab
[Musik]
ein alter Fuchs wie er hat
möglicherweise erkannt dass man in
diesen Spiel als Premierminister er
verlieren wird und es noch besser ist
ein wenig abzuwarten denn kaum zwei
Wochen im Amt musstest du nach bereits
verkünden dass eine Reihe von Plänen die
für ihn und die Konservativen Priorität
hatten auf unbestimmte Zeit verschoben
werden es geht aber nicht nur um
zentrale Punkte des Wahlprogramms der
konservativen mit denen sie 2019 die
Wahlen gewonnen hatten sondern auch um
seine eigenen politischen Kern Thesen
die ein Sommer vorgestellt hatte als er
sich zum ersten Mal um das Amt des
trainierst beworben hatte das aber dann
an Trust ging egal ob es um Einwanderung
den Schutz öffentlicher Grünflächen vor
megalomanen Bauprojekten oder neue
Regeln für Vorsorgeuntersuchungen im
maroden Gesundheitswesen geht überall
musst du nach nun einen Rückzieher nach
dem anderen verkünden der Grund die
miese wirtschaftliche Situation mit
anderen Worten es ist kein Geld da die
Kehrtwende Ende Oktober betrat auch die
Absage der Pläne die Erdgasförderung
durch Fracking zu erlauben das groß
angekündigte versprechen die noch
während der Mitgliedschaft
Großbritannien ist in der EU
verabschiedeten Gesetze innerhalb der
nächsten 100 Tage zu überarbeiten wird
also nicht erfüllt die Pläne zur Reform
und Vereinfachung des
einwanderungssystems sind auf Eis gelegt
dabei waren sie eines der großen
Versprechen des brexit die derzeitige
Praxis Migranten in Hotels
unterzubringen während die Behörden über
ihren Asylantrag entscheiden wird also
vorerst nicht abgeschafft die Briten
Zahlen jeden Tag Millionen von Pfund für
diese Hotels zu denen auch fünf
sterne-häuser gehören auch die
Verpflichtung des 80% der Asylanträge
innerhalb von sechs Monaten entschieden
werden sollen wird auch unbestimmte Zeit
verschoben angesichts der Tatsache dass
derzeit nur 4% der Anträge innerhalb
dieser Zeit bearbeitet werden ist dieses
Versprechen ohnehin nicht zu halten und
es ist egal ob es eben um das
einwanderungs- oder das
Gesundheitssystem das Bauwesen oder die
kümmerliche industrielle Basis geht
obwohl eigentlich kein Geld da ist
regiert weiterhin der Wahnsinn auf der
Insel die immer knapper werdenden Mittel
werden für vollkommen kafkaeske
ineffiziente Dinge aus dem Fenster
geworfen lange wird es wohl nicht mehr
gut gehen können die Reserven aus den
fetten Jahren sind irgendwann eben
aufgebraucht aber jetzt seid erstmal
dran welche ökonomische Therapie würdet
ihr dem Land verordnen kann Regie so
nach den Karren aus dem Dreck ziehen
oder sollten wir bei visualpolitik schon
mal anfangen auch seinen politischen
Nachruf zu schreiben wird er derjenige
sein der die Briten wieder zurück in die
EU führen wird oder müssen sie dafür auf
die nächste leberregierung warten wie
immer sind auf eure Antworten und eine
angeregte Diskussion zu diesem heißen
Thema schon sehr gespannt ich hoffe dass
euch dieses Video gefallen hat ihr
vielleicht etwas dabei gelernt habt was
ja gibt uns bitte ein Like teilt mit
euren Freunden und vergiss nicht das Abo
mit Glöckchen und keines unserer Videos
mehr zu verpassen natürlich freuen uns
auch jederzeit über eine Spende von euch
mit uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
mach's gut und bis bald
[Musik]